it goes without saying that regis
philbin brought joy to so many people on
camera
and off and he always shared his unique
sense of humor with us
here at e.t i'm gonna give them the
television show of their life
he wakes up in the morning wants to be
with reaches
and here i am you want to be with me
aren't you yeah
how many people can i handle you know
what i'm saying don't we look good
together we
do look nice let's go
we're having a baby what a wonderful day
and a beautiful night and a baby
i don't have the heart to tell him he's
not the father i just
i really don't have the heart and he's
so happy he stopped but anyway
regis spent 28 years on live making
daytime tv magic with two funny ladies
kelly ripa and kathy lee she's here i
can't believe you're still even speaking
to me now that you've saved the network
and everything
so important but nevertheless that for
15 years i finally believe you
i don't forget my old friends the
mornings were filled with sniping
snapping and throwing
shade but we always knew it was all an
act like when kathie lee
roasted regis over who spent more time
in their dressing room
regis by far i could barely pull you
away from the mirror oh no
actually i spent more time in tom
selleck's dressing room but in her
dreams
she spends more time in tom selleck's
dressing room next question
i love the bahamas kathy lee really what
have you been doing well i've been
feeding the iguanas and wrestling with
the sharks
what have you been doing beating cody
and cassidy and wrestling frank
i told you it was fun e.t had an open
invitation whenever these two hit the
road whether it was swimming with the
sharks
really really spectacular stuff or
hitting the waves in hawaii
the getting here is really rough oh do
you know what it's like to travel with
this man
please 14 hours dropped on a plane with
kathie lee
my eyes balls are spinning at disney
world
reeds was our special e.t correspondent
take a look at that a.t
yeah regis philbin here direct from
sunny florida hi everybody it's me regis
[Music]
yeah well not too big is it yeah
i don't know where kathy lee is she's
swimming down there hey gentlemen
where's your camera croix he's got all
the funny stuff
once again 80 cameras are here where the
hell are our guys
as host of who wants to be a millionaire
rege went prime time and took over our
e.t
mic when they had celebrity guests i got
you something
yeah what you got i brought you these
flowers beautiful thank you jimmy yeah
you're welcome
get rid of it kelly shared the stage
with regis for 10 years celebrating
everything from weddings to halloween
this is his personal best
kelly calls rege her mentor and a class
act
and like all of us thanks regis for
making the world
a better place it's my reach i really
got a chance to
appreciate how funny he is so funny made
me laugh every day
i hope i see you again real soon thanks
everybody
who is it i'm waiting for a fedex
christmas 1998 regis and joy showed e.t
how they celebrate inside their
connecticut home she loves jewelry she
loves things
well now reed just don't make me sound
so shallow
yes my man regis was feeling the spirit
until we asked about caroline
who goes caroline will you stop it
caroling yeah we put on funny hats down
to the
neighbor's house me he was an american
[Music]
original